[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magazine informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre es
liliana valencia aquí damos una mirada
en profundidad los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
el ex presidente de costa de marfil
laurent gbagbo regresó al país una
década después de que se negara a
reconocer la derrota en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2010 después de las
cuales el país vivió meses de violencia
que dejaron más de 3000 muertos se
realizaron en argelia las primeras
elecciones desde el inicio del estallido
social en febrero de 2019 estas fueron
las elecciones más baja participación en
la historia del país y la causa sería el
llamado al boicot por parte del
movimiento de protestas conocido como
gigante y cada 16 de junio se conmemora
el día del niño africano la fecha fue
instaurada por la unión africana a
partir de 1991 para visibilizar y buscar
soluciones a las problemáticas que
enfrenta la niñez en el continente la
educación la lucha contra el vih/sida la
pobreza extrema entre otros son algunos
de los principales retos
iniciamos entonces con la información en
áfrica siete días porque tras diez años
de ausencia el ex presidente de costa de
marfil laurent gbagbo regresó a su país
después de que la corte penal
internacional lo absolviera de cuatro
cargos por crímenes de lesa humanidad
aunque todavía ha de presentarse a la
justicia en su país ya que en 2019 fue
condenado a 20 años de cárcel por
corrupción en 2010 bajo se negó a
aceptar la derrota en las elecciones
presidenciales lo que generó meses de
violencia y miles de muertos
el 31 de marzo de 2021 la corte penal
internacional confirmó la decisión de
absolver a logan bajo de crímenes contra
la humanidad la sala de apelaciones
revoca todas las condiciones restantes
para la liberación debajo tras esta
sentencia
aunque lo que está en el centro del
procedimiento judicial que comenzó en
enero de 2016 es el conflicto entre los
dos políticos los hechos que forman
parte de la investigación se remontan a
finales de 2010 tras unas elecciones
presidenciales con muy reñidas las
tensiones entre bad boy utara aumentaron
cuando la comisión electoral de costa de
marfil le dio la victoria al asad para
con el 54,1 por ciento de los votos algo
respaldado por la onu pero estos
resultados fueron invalidados al día
siguiente por el consejo constitucional
que proclamó la victoria de laurent
gbagbo iniciando la incertidumbre que
sumió el país en el caos por cinco meses
los partidarios de los dos bandos se
enfrentaron y la violencia derivada
acabó con la vida de más de tres mil
personas
pero la bomba no cedió ni un centímetro
de terreno junto a sus seguidores a
gameplay ud fue acusado de ordenar
violaciones y asesinatos de sus
opositores en abril de 2011 fue detenido
con la ayuda del ejército francés y
trasladado a la haya donde se enfrentó a
cuatro cargos por crímenes de lesa
humanidad los cuales negó tras un juicio
de tres años en el que declararon 82
testigos las pruebas con trabajo y
bloqueo se consideraron insuficientes y
los dos hombres fueron absueltos en
enero de 2019 decisión confirmada por la
sala de apelación de la cpi en 2021
falleció a los 97 años el ex presidente
y héroe de la independencia de zambia
kenneth kaunda en un hospital militar de
lusaka la capital donde estaba siendo
tratado por neumonía la familia confirmó
el deceso del ex mandatario que dirigió
los destinos del país desde 1964 en la
nación del sur de áfrica obtuvo su
independencia del reino unido y hasta
1991 después de finalizar su extenso
mandato
unda se convirtió en uno de los
activistas africanos más comprometidos
en la lucha contra el sida
y vamos ahora hasta argelia donde el
partido en el poder el frente de
liberación nacional fue la fuerza más
votada en las elecciones legislativas
unos comicios con la menor participación
de la historia del país cuatro de cada
cinco argelinos llamados a las urnas no
participó una cifra que se explica en
gran medida en el llamado al boicot por
parte de la oposición estos fueron los
primeros comicios legislativos después
del estadio social que inició en febrero
de 2019 con una participación mínima el
frente de liberación nacional ganó las
elecciones legislativas los resultados
definitivos dan al partido en el poder
un cuarto de los escaños de la asamblea
nacional argelina en primera posición
del frente de liberación nacional obtuvo
105 escaños seguido de las listas de
candidatos independientes que
consiguieron 78 escaños lo que significa
un cambio remarcable en el escenario
político argelino ya que se convierten
en la segunda fuerza de la cámara baja
del parlamento en tercera posición el
msp el partido islamista moderado se
lleva 64 escaños a pesar
de que reivindicó la victoria el día
siguiente de las elecciones el aliado
tradicional del frente de liberación
nacional la agrupación nacional para la
democracia queda en cuarto lugar con 57
parlamentarios ambos partidos están
desprestigiados porque se les asocia con
el gobierno del ex presidente buteflika
pero la fuerza en el poder podrá
mantener sus alianzas y seguir con su
hoja de ruta aún así la victoria del
frente de liberación nacional es
relativa la fuerza pierde más de 50
escaños en unas elecciones rechazadas en
masa por la población argelina sólo 5
millones de personas de las 24 llamadas
a las urnas fueron a votar para elegir
los 407 diputados de la asamblea por los
próximos cinco años se trata del índice
de participación más bajo en al menos
los últimos 20 años en unas legislativas
fueron múltiples las llamadas al boicot
lanzadas sobre todo por militantes del
movimiento e irak que señala que el
poder sigue en manos del establishment
militar también en etiopía se realizaron
elecciones parlamentarias después de que
fueran aplazadas dos veces debido a la
pandemia de kobe 19
de la comunidad internacional están
puestos en la nación debido al conflicto
en la región norte ya de tigre que ha
llevado a miles de personas a soportar
hambrunas y al desplazamiento forzado el
objetivo es renovar los 547 escaños de
la cámara de representantes populares de
etiopía y también los consejos
regionales en los cuales se estima se
consolida el apoyo hacia el primer
ministro había ahmet problemas de
seguridad generado que un cuarto de las
circunscripciones no pudieran organizar
los comicios unos comicios que desde
hace un año han sido aplazados varias
veces debido a la crisis sanitaria y a
la violencia que golpea la región de
tigre tenemos muchas esperanzas en estas
elecciones son muy importantes para la
estabilidad de nuestro país vine para
rezar por la paz y la unidad no hemos
tenido comida durante mucho tiempo
apenas podíamos pagar el pan hemos visto
demasiado sufrimiento causado por la
economía y los problemas de seguridad
queremos un futuro mejor
nombrado en 2018 el primer ministro de
etiopía despertó la esperanza de unidad
en un país donde conviven más de 80
comunidades étnicas
sin embargo había ahmed premio nobel de
la paz en 2019 perdió su reputación con
el incremento de la violencia sectaria
durante su mandato hoy el jefe del
gobierno quiere reforzar su legitimidad
en las urnas
matt no tenemos delante nuestro la
elección entre la destrucción y el
desarrollo
quiero llamarlos a unirse a proteger su
país y hacerlo prosperar me diga mi
terry en la cav la chufa legal debido a
la guerra un quinto de las
circunscripciones no pudieron organizar
la votación por lo que en ciertas
regiones fue pospuesta para el mes de
septiembre en el tigre donde los
enfrentamientos y la hambruna no cesan
no hay fecha fijada las elecciones serán
observadas de cerca por la comunidad
internacional inquieta por la exclusión
de un número tan alto de electores
pasamos a temas culturales porque este
año se realiza la tercera versión del
chip de áfrica film festival una
iniciativa creada para conectar el cine
africano desde una de las ciudades con
mayor porcentaje de población afro en
colombia
el kit de áfrica film festival 2021 se
realiza simultáneamente de la ciudad de
punta negra en congo brazzaville y la
ciudad de quibdó capital del
departamento de chocó en colombia tendrá
sesiones tanto virtuales como
presenciales y las convocatorias están
abiertas para que ellos que quieran
postular sus películas de brazaville
wifried massamba el director del caf nos
cuenta más hola soy wifi massamba
director del caf kit de áfrica film
festival los invito a postular su
película para la tercera edición de
nuestro festival desde el congo el modo
presencial y de manera virtual para
colombia y el resto del mundo vamos a
tener evitar internacional director
productor y periodista también un jurado
muy internacional por ejemplo con johnny
index que destroza y otros los demás de
áfrica entonces desde el pongo de manera
presencial vamos a estar aquí para
esperarlos pero para estar aquí tienes
postular mostrar sus películas entonces
desde
en mi país el kombu los invito a todo el
director para presentar su trabajo su
producción su película para la tercera
edición del café y áfrica fin festival
lo esperamos un diamante de mil 98
quilates que se cree es el tercero más
grande del mundo fue descubierto en
botsuana la piedra fue entregada al
presidente de mockus sin más y si el
diamante mide siete puntos tres
centímetros de largo 5.2 de ancho y 2.7
de espesor y no podría haber llegado en
mejor momento después de que la pandemia
de ccoo y 19 golpeara las ventas de
diamantes en el país durante el 2020
cada 16 de junio se conmemora el día del
niño africano una fecha declarada por la
unión africana desde 1991 con el
objetivo de reflexionar acerca de los
derechos de los niños en el continente
que muchas veces se ven afectados por la
pobreza extrema la falta de acceso a la
educación y la salud y los conflictos
armados previamente hablamos con asia
ismail fundadora y directora de la ong
save a walk the fire gration quien desde
madrid españa nos contó cuáles son los
retos del continente en materia de
primera infancia los retos de los niños
africanos
el principal reto es la extrema pobre
esté más pobreza pues conlleva que no
tengan educación por ejemplo te lleva
que los niños tengan que trabajar a una
edad muy temprana
y lleva a que las niñas le tengan que
cazar para poder tener una cabra autor
en las zonas de conflicto donde hay
guerras que los utilicen como son niños
contados
entonces esto eso contribuye el que no
tenga en el desarrollo adecuado no como
por ejemplo un niño que puede haber
nacido en otro lugar
esto le disputen a la educación también
muchos de ellos no tengan bastante la
mayoría de los veintes en educación
primaria y 3 plica pero no tienen
aspecto ha querido que los colegios a lo
mejor están tan lejos de los niños pero
pueden acudir o no pueden comprar ni
siquiera vivir porque no los padres
están tan pobres una de las cosas
también son familias muy interesantes
con muy poco dinero tienen digamos
muchísimos que por tanto lo hablamos por
el lugar todo lo que nos quedan muchos
nuestros trabajos para celebrar un día
del niño y también a propósito de la
conmemoración del día del niño africano
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con este videoclip que nos
llega desde uganda donde los populares
más acá kits bailan la canción tú a
llegarle del cantante también ugandés de
dickens o
y con esta buena música finalizamos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días ustedes
pueden continuar con más de nuestra
página web france24 puntocom para
ampliar la información de américa latina
y el mundo quédense con nosotros esto es
trans 24
[Música]
vale
saltemos una monoboya y tuvimos
[Música]